right more now on the battle for
Fallujah and i'm joined by arash aramesh
the national security analyst he's in
San Francisco good morning arash thank
you so much for joining us oh you're in
houston I apologize Arash thanks for
joining us how close do you think these
troops are to retake in Fallujah it's a
good to join you from a flooded and soon
to be more flooded Houston yeah I have
to write I definitely have to but I do
have the weather report in sky it's very
important the city of Fallujah was one
of the very first major Sunni cities
that fell into Isis hands early on
almost thought a year and a half two
years ago before Mosul and other cities
felt to Isis but let's keep in mind
while Fallujah may not be the most
important strategic city in a military
sense it is very important for many
symbolic reasons it's the heartland it's
a Sunni heartland and it's very
important symbolically to Sunnis to form
a Baathist it's the sort of the center
and the centerpiece of what used to be
the insurgency the Sunni insurgency
against American and British forces and
the coalition occupation of Iraq and now
forces Islamist forces the remnants
about al-qaeda in Iraq and also former
Baathists and Saddam sort of officials
and remnants have formed to get built
together this coalition as we know as
Isis today and have form sort of their
stronghold in places like Fallujah so
Fallujah is much much much more
important as a simple as it would ever
be as a very important strategic town
it's fall to the hands of the Iraqi army
will be significant and what about what
happens after let's say they retake
Fallujah then what for the city because
most of the residents have fled what do
you think would lie in store for the
city and it makes you wonder you know
usually people who can't flee a city
that has been surrounded not for a for
quite a while a besieged city usually
those who can flee are the weakest there
are the elderly there are children there
there are unarmed and you know poorly
sort of people in poor health
women and children and the elderly so
those who are now in the city of
estimated about 50,000 people happen to
be the most vulnerable in that city now
what's gonna happen the Iraqi army is
now being aided by Iranian backed shia
militias there is no love lost between
Sunni sort of radicals and these Shia
militias Grand Ayatollah Ali Sistani he
is the most senior Shia cleric in Iraq
has come out and issued a verdict or an
edict saying you know the Shia's have to
be nice and humane towards as soon as
they captured but a lot of people would
probably rightly assume that with the
absence of Western and other
organizations and human rights observers
there is going to be a lot of bloodshed
as Isis did against the Shia's and Shias
may probably retaliate and do so against
the sunny so it's not going to be a very
pretty scene and it's not going to be
fought along you know a Geneva
Convention rules what about these claims
are ash that is is within months of
defeat what do you make of those you
know the organization known as Isis
maybe on sort of their way out on you
know and under demise but I don't think
the idea the concept of a Sunni
insurgency has any way near finished
let's let's assume for a second that
Isis had a different name Isis is a
conglomerate of very upset Sunnis urban
cities rural Sundanese sydney's who came
from a secular Iraq from a Saddam regime
era soon as he came from a much more
conservative sunni religious islamist
background the [ __ ] this conglomerate
this coalition created the Islamic state
if you look at the actual battle
commanders and leaders of most artists
factions and Isis divisions it goes back
to 1802 a battle train soon DC no Saddam
Hussein Baptist official so it is it
going to be completely defeated probably
not do we need to deal them a very
significant military blow and take as
much land away from them as possible to
take away from there
legitimacy absolutely but this issue is
a political issue at the end of the day
yes defeat them militarily or break
their backs as much as you can but at
the end of the day you've got to bring
them in as long as there is this sense
of being marginalized amongst the Sunni
community both in Syria and especially
in Iraq there will be some element just
like Isis to rise up and create mayhem a
rush do you think it's moved beyond that
sunni-shia divide because you do have
sony forces fighting against is you have
some tribal forces and these forces were
much much more significant just a few
years back when General Petraeus at the
time the commander of US forces in Iraq
and then later as the commander of US
forces central command's he sort of
especially when it was leading the fight
in Iraq as commander of US forces and
coalition forces in Iraq he devised the
coin manual the counterinsurgency
operation manual and also implemented
his his vision in Iraq which was to
clear and to holster in the areas at the
time yes we did get a lot of support
from the tribe from Sunni tribes but
that you know support from Sunni tribes
really evaporated and went away when the
[ __ ] government of former Prime Minister
Nuri al-maliki in Iraq started
implementing very harsh sectarian
policies and and I'm again this is not a
one-way highway you cannot find one
group of one political party or one sec
that is fully an entirely guilty of all
evils that's not just that's just simply
not the case but yes there are some
Sunnis fighting alongside the Iraqi army
and Shiite militias that are backed by
Iran and ironically getting us and
coalition air support but it is not that
significant it is not what it used to be
back in 07 and 08 so a rush after this
is Mosul next if Fallujah Falls muscles
next Mosul is a much more important city
strategically size-wise you name it
Mosul is the second largest city in Iraq
after Mosul fell to Isis without much
resistance as a matter of fact by you
know from Iraqi forces it was a huge
deal over a billion dollars in cash was
captured by Isis a lot of american-made
weaponary weapons and ammunition was
captured by Isis most
is a big deal now those who are fighting
on the motional funds happen to be a lot
of Kurdish Peshmerga fighters coming
from the Kurdish regions up regions of
northern Iraq that itself could
potentially create some tension between
the Iraqi army and the Iraqi central
government that the government that
wants to see Isis gone and the Kurds who
also would like to see Isis gone but
they do not want to see each other
dominant over the city of Mosul so again
in these cases in the very complicated
sort of battles of the Mideast
especially in Iraq and Syria the enemy
of my enemy is not always necessarily my
friend and that just makes things a lot
more complicated okay arash thank you
very much national security analyst
Arash aramesh talking to us from Houston
death thanks